I have to ask you about this.
I see it every day I come here.
It's a crocheted pillow,
(Sarah chuckles)
with the face of you Sarah Silverman,
and it's here,
we've had it steam cleaned because,
well that's just what you do with anything
that's been sitting around the Largo.
What is the story-
So many people have sat,
I'm sure it's covered in fecal
matter and like dried semen.
[Conan] Yeah.
I mean it's a little distorted.
Well first of all,
why is there a crocheted pillow
with your face on it here at Largo?
Explain.
That needs an explanation?
Yes, it does.
No, it does have an explanation.
About five years ago I think,
I won't go into the whole
story but I almost died.
I remember this.
Randomly.
You had a medical emergency yes.
Yeah. I had like a thing,
abscess on the top of my windpipe
it was either gonna choke me to death
or poison me to death if it exploded.
It's just one of those crazy things.
I had a surgery where they told my manager
and my boyfriend at the time
it was like 50-50 chance of survival.
[Conan] Oh my God.
But I am fine.
But I was in an induced coma for a week.
And my other friend named
Coco, Mark Coco Cohen,
he didn't know what to do with himself
he felt so helpless.
And he crochets,
and as matter of fact when
he first started crocheting
he crocheted a huge blanket,
he felt emasculated by his new passion,
so he wrote the word
twat in the middle of it.
Just like a huge crocheted anyway.
You know grandma Moses
made a lot of those.
(laughs)
Yeah such a sweet...
Look check out, look for that on Etsy.
But-
So he was so,
he didn't know what to do with himself,
so he crocheted a pillow
with my face on it.
And then when I got out of the hospital
he gave it to me and it meant so much
'cause I knew it just was made with love.
But then, I live in this little apartment.
[Conan] Right.
I was with Flanigan,
and I go, I love Mark so much
and I love that he made this,
but I can't have a
pillow with my face on it
in my three-room apartment.
And he said, "Bring it on down to."
I can't do accents.
Ah, bring it on down to the theater!
(both laugh)
Bring it on down to Largo.
[Man] Watch out for the Row
and El Duce heads.
(Conan chuckles)
We kick it around like a Mussolini head.
You see that's what everybody
does with the stuff they are
too embarrassed to have in their house.
There's an oil painting
of Zach Galifianakis,
and Jeff Garlin painting,
and everyone just brings
it's ink source.
Right.
'Cause they don't want to throw it out,
but they can't have it in their home.
Right. If it means a great deal to you,
which you wanted to sit
in an abandoned theater,
bring it to Largo.
(both chuckle)
I think that's a Fiona Apple song.
Where the Tidal love her.
It probably is.
It should be if it isn't.